the Joe Rogan experience while their
fury - to me is the heavyweight fight
that's the heavyweight fight I'm really
interested in this fight Joshua third
I thought schewe Joshua's like it used
to be Joshua number one the golden child
and you know I've seen lost so he fell
off but wildin fury have just been doing
their thing man well this is the fight
that I want to see more than anything is
wild of fury - that's the number one -
just because the first one was so
controversial and fantastic so good and
you know I rewatched it yesterday in
fact you can make a real real solid
argument that Tyson Fury got robbed a
hundred percent they don't the only
argument for Deontay Wilder is you know
he did knock him down Oh dad if the
fight was a fight if it's a fight fight
you know like in the streets and two
guys were going at it like that and one
guy dropped the guy and blasted him and
then dropped him in the end and who's
laying on his back and he got up and
they you know at the end of the round
they decided it was the end of the fight
you would say man I think he won he
[ __ ] that dude up but as far as boxing
rules goals and contests purely one that
[ __ ] whoever won the box you're on fest
but Deontay Wilder I like to draw them
because jianchi Walter had did the most
damage in the fight so I was like
alright when is the drum like oh I dig
that here's the argument against the
draw though he gets dropped
Tyson fearing is dropped in the the
final round right loses one point for
sure right it's definitely now a 10-8
round for Tyson for Deontay Wilder after
that knockdown is a bad knockdown but
then he gets up and wins the rest of the
rounds the wrestler so what do you say
there you give a point for that so you
know Fury won the fight so what is it
nine eight what is that then if it's a
10-point must system how does that work
does that mean then would it go back to
even can you have a seven seven round
you both drop each other twice I don't
think so I don't think so no right what
happens there
do you ever imagine guys that wouldn't
just go back that you want to score that
round ten eight you'd do a ten shouldn't
we know this it just be a ten nine I
should I should definitely know this
boxing judges but even we use the same
scores in the UFC don't think dude
[Applause]